[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today our force is real
a force is an action that changes the
movement of an object
usually an object tends to conserve its
motion
in particular its direction and speed
sometimes however it happens to change
direction or speed
something happens changing its movement
and we say that it experiences
a force
at first glance we can classify all
forces in the universe
into three categories first
we can think of the force that pulls us
back when a car accelerates
or the centrifugal force that pushes us
to one side when it turns
these kinds of forces are called
inertial forces
they most often appear inside a vehicle
when it changes speed or direction
secondly we can think of forces that act
at a distance
the two main ones being gravity which
attract massive objects together and
electromagnetism which attracts or
repels charges and magnets
finally the third category groups all
contact forces
[Music]
these are the forces of pressure
traction torsion
and deformation or even friction
all these forces have the property of
acting locally
through a physical contact between two
objects
these three categories are enough to
account for all forces in the universe
but are these forces real do they exist
fundamentally or are they rather
consequences of
other phenomena to answer this question
we'll look at each category one by one
first let's start with inertial forces
as an example we can imagine a passenger
inside a car
[Music]
when the car starts to move an inertial
force appears
pushing the passenger back into his seat
from his point of view when the car
accelerates a force appears
and pulls all objects to the rear
at first glance for the passenger this
force exists
it has to be accounted for in order to
understand why objects are drawn
backwards
[Music]
but if he looks out the window the
passenger realizes he's not the only one
to experience this force
when the car starts all objects in the
universe seem to move backwards all
together
as this same force applies everywhere
[Music]
when we think about it this situation is
absurd
how could the car influence our whole
universe instantly
we would never expect a star at the
other end of the cosmos
to be influenced by the movement of a
car and even less so
instantaneously
to resolve this paradox we actually just
need to change the point of view
instead of saying that all objects are
drawn backwards except the car
we rather observe from the outside and
say that it's the car which undergoes a
forward force while the rest of the
universe stays still
the passenger thinks there is a force
because he is observing from
inside the car which is itself subject
to a force
the friction of the wheels against the
[Music]
ground
this way of thinking is very general and
applies to all
inertial forces all these forces seem
ubiquitous
they seem to act everywhere
instantaneously
from this we deduce that they cannot be
real forces
they are only illusions fictitious
forces
which appear because we locate ourselves
in a frame which itself
is subject to a force
having said that we realize that
inertial forces are not the only ones
that seem to act everywhere at the same
time
this also applies to the second category
actions
at a distance
first let's consider gravity
when we drop an apple the apple is
accelerated towards the ground
and we say that it undergoes a downward
force the pull of the earth
as long as the apple has not touched the
ground it seems constantly attracted by
the earth
at a distance but the apple is not the
only thing affected
all objects in the universe also seem to
be attracted by the earth
as if the planet were inflicting the
same force universally
to all bodies that exist
like the previous example we can ask
ourselves how reasonable it is to think
that the earth could influence the
entire universe
after all as with the car it would be
simpler to say that the universe is not
influenced by the earth that it is not
the objects that all fall
downwards but simply the ground that
rises
upwards like the inertial force in the
car
the force of gravity would only be an
illusion it would appear when we observe
from the ground whereas it is precisely
the ground
which accelerates
at first this vision seems more elegant
instead of inventing a mysterious force
gravity
it suffices to say that it is the ground
that rises
objects seem to come closer to the
ground not because they
fall but because the surface accelerates
upwards
having said that it's easy to see that
this explanation alone
is flawed indeed if it were
the ground which accelerated why
wouldn't the planet grow bigger over
time
if the ground indeed moves outwards we
should observe that the earth expands
and it would eventually blow up yet
earth has not changed size for billions
of years
and objects continue to fall at its
surface
[Music]
the answer to this problem is very
subtle and constitutes one of the most
shocking discoveries in modern physics
the ground does rise its surface is
constantly accelerating outwards
because it is pushed by the pressure of
the materials that make the earth
if the planet does not grow it is
because the space
all around it the fabric in which it is
contained
shrinks in the opposite direction
this phenomenon is called space-time
curvature
the earth does not directly influence
objects in the universe
the planet is only growing outwards
because of its pressure
but as it is very massive the earth also
compresses the fabric of the universe
in the opposite direction the planet
grows into a space that contracts
and the two effects balance each other
this way of understanding the universe
is called general relativity
we introduce the fact that space-time
gets curved to get rid of gravity
much like the inertial force inside the
car gravity
is an illusion we observe that the apple
falls downwards
while it is in reality the surface which
is subject to a force
the pressure of the planet that prevents
it from collapsing in on itself
we now understand that gravity is merely
another inertial force
and we are left with two categories only
actions at a distance
including electromagnetic forces and
contact forces
but if we think about it contact forces
are only approximations
in reality the matter that makes up
objects is made up of atoms
when we observe a contact force at our
scale it is really an interaction
between the atoms of each of the two
objects
when we push an object for example the
contact force does not really exist
it is only the sum at our scale of all
the electromagnetic forces in play
that repel electrons and therefore atoms
between our hand and the object
ultimately contact forces are nothing
more than the manifestation at
our scale of the electromagnetic force
[Music]
therefore apart from inertial forces
which are illusions
the only real forces in the universe
seem to be the fundamental interactions
that occur at the scale of particles
in our universe we identify three of
these
the electromagnetic interaction which
explains why electrons repel each other
and which explains all contact forces
the strong
interaction which explains the cohesion
of protons and neutrons within atoms
and finally the weak interaction from
which radioactivity arises
alone these three fundamental
interactions
describe the forces that act upon all
particles
[Music]
yet one last problem remains although we
have successfully identified the three
fundamental forces in the universe
they still seem to act at a distance
when we approach two electrons for
example they repel each other at a
distance
as if the electrons could communicate
without coming into contact
[Music]
again this situation seems absurd how
could two electrons
interact when they are separated by some
distance
in reality all goes as if the electrons
were two people playing catch
when one electron throws the ball at the
other the symmetry of the situation
forces the electron to move
back in the opposite direction
to understand if we consider that the
electron and the ball form a single
object
and that this object has no reason to
move over time
when the ball is thrown towards the
right the electron is forced to move
towards the left
to compensate while giving a movement to
the ball
the electron has also acquired a
movement in the opposite direction
and this is precisely what we call a
force
this way of understanding fundamental
interactions
come from what we call quantum field
theory
along with general relativity these are
the two theories
at the basis of all modern physics
quantum field theory tells us that
particles are constantly exchanging
messengers
which we call virtual particles
these are photons for the
electromagnetic force
gluons for the strong interaction and z
and w
bosons for the weak interaction
by symmetry all these exchanges of
virtual particles
gradually change the motion of objects
and it is this recoil effect
when a particle emits or absorbs a
virtual particle
that we interpret at our scale as a
force
to conclude it would be wrong to say
that forces do not exist
ultimately inside a moving car objects
are well described by an inertial force
but this force is just a tool a
mathematical description that works in
the car's frame of reference
inertial forces like the centrifugal
force the coriolis force
and even the force of gravity are in the
end all mere illusions that disappear
when we take an appropriate point of
view
having said that there still seems to be
a multitude of
real physical forces called contact
forces
forces of pressure tension or friction
all these forces allow us to describe
the interaction between
bodies at our scale
but when we dive into matter we realize
that these contact forces
are only large-scale approximations in
reality they emerge from
simply three fundamental forces which
alone
explain the evolution of all particles
with that being said these three basic
forces are not themselves really
fundamental as they ultimately emerge
from much
simpler purer and more natural notion
inherent to the geometry and structure
of the universe itself
which we often refer to as action
reaction
this is the notion of symmetry
[Music]
you